everyone hello hello oh my god i'm so fucked up i literally
just woke up like like i think 20 minutes ago so i guess i
forgot to throw i was like oh shit gotta tweet out that i'll
be live on twitch um let me let me i didn't even i didn't
even quote retweet myself give me a sec guys i'm oh i'm all
over the place i'm all over the place all right live Now, I
should have so many things I gotta do.
I'm a little behind.
Perfect.
Hey, hey, hey.
I have to remind you guys.
Sunday is my off day.
My body is not used to working on a Sunday, guys.
I gotta remind you all.
This body always is like trained, has been trained to be
like Sunday is off day.
Like, I am the muscle memory.
It's not yet ready right now, so let me live now.
All right, it'll be a show match.
It is, we play three matches, and then I don't know what
else we're going to do after that.
We might just chill a little bit.
I might do some work stuff while I stream.
Devil, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I think I, I don't know.
I didn't stream all week.
I like, I did like guerrilla streams.
I think majority of my streams were on, well, actually, it's
like half, half.
I was going to say it was like half on Twitch.
Twitch and a half on YouTube.
I didn't warm up at all.
I did Doom queue after my stream.
I had a headache from coughing a lot last night.
And I was like, you know what's going to fix this?
I'm going to start Doom queuing.
And you want to know how it went?
I'm almost about to lose Celestial 2.
yeah so it didn't go so well it did not go as well as i
thought who would have thought playing video games with a
headache is not a great idea also it was weekend queues no
it was crazy i swear to god the moment i went the moment i
queued up off stream um at the gate like it was back it was
back
It got very doomy.
It really did.
All right, give me a sec.
So today, for those who are wondering why I am live on a
Sunday, because it is my...
Okay.
All right, I just thought, okay, I gotta do an important DM
real quick, guys.
I gotta, sorry, I'm like, I gotta do it in...
I gotta do an important message real quick, work message
real quick.
Everybody, everybody isn't even here.
Like, okay, as long as I'm not the last person in the VC, it
should...
Oh, it's because the matches are...
Sorry.
Okay, I forgot.
Let me double check.
Yeah, sorry.
I'm all over the place right now.
Sunday is my off day, so...
Sunday is my off day, so, like, my brain is like, why are
you alive right now?
Why are you working?
You're supposed to be still sleeping, and I'm catching up to
your sleep debt.
But anyway, I was invited to do the show...
show match uh for the j3 community clash tournament um
before the before their finals um and uh it's gonna be for
three matches we have to have a deadpool in our game which
that would mean that is flats um so my team will be flats
craiggy day malaya lulu and me and we are against booger fan
fan rain Kingsman and Moxie and what's crazy is that J3
purposely included three supports on each team so no matter
what we're gonna be playing with three supports we're gonna
be playing triple support against triple support that mad
man that absolute mad man
he really did that to us he really got to be playing triple
support the entire three games because all three it's not
like all three of us the three supports on each team does
not really flex
um right she thank you for those ray thank you thank you I
hope you have, uh, I hope you have a great stream.
Uh, this is gonna be so fun.
Um, anyway, uh, making a true support theme.
So it's gonna be one, two, three for the, it's like one
tank, two DPS, three supports.
Anyway, ah, where was that?
Okay, I got to shoot an important DM real quick.
Let me finish this DM super quick.
Uh, I can't even read out the DM while I'm typing.
I can't even read out what I'm typing, too, because I can't
spoil it.
It's something very important behind the scenes work.
I was going to do this when I woke up, and I didn't realize
I was going to wake up around 1 to 2 p.m.
I thought I was going to wake up earlier, but my body was
like, you got to catch up on that sleep debt because you are
so fucked up right now, and I'm like, You're so right.
You're so right, but good.
And then my body's like, it's a good thing.
Sunday's your off day.
And my body did not get the memo that Sunday, unfortunately,
was not my off day today.
My mind knew it.
My body not so much.
My body was just like, oh, good thing.
Today's your off day.
You can sleep as much as you want.
Sadly, that, sadly, that is not true.
All right, here we go.
Let's see it.
All right.
I shot my... I shot the DM.
Let's hope that...
Let's see.
All right.
I sent my message.
Let's hope that...
They saw my DM.
Can't say what it is.
I had to do a work message real quick.
Oh my god, that thing got...
I like clicked something.
I was like, oh my god, it was my...
It was my Chrome on.
Like, it was my Chrome on.
Oh my... Sorry, I'm a mess right now.
I really have...
I'm a fucking mess at the moment.
All right.
What else?
What else did I want to say?
Oh, yes.
Anniversary.
I will reveal the special anniversary trailer after the show
match.
I will type the tweet live on stream.
And we can all react to it together after the show match,
guys.
Yeah.
Okay, let me shoot my...
Man, I'll join a message real quick.
Yeah, it'll be after the show match, so you gotta...
You gotta stay to the end.
And my brain is very slow.
My brain is very slow today.
It really is.
I literally...
I'm not ready to work.
I'm not ready to work at all.
Like, I'm not ready.
I don't think I'll ever be ready.
Are they even close to done with their games?
by the way i i don't even know let me double let me check
all right where is the j3 tournament what's the score
currently what's the current score or did they just finished
one two is it best of three or wait no that doesn't make
sense it can't be best of three it's already three games
best of five sorry i can't sorry best of i was like wait no
that's already three games why are they still going up is it
it's best of five right oh my god there's two more games
left okay uh shoot they use the twitch prize they can thank
you they said it oh oh j3 didn't expect the other team to
take a boy so they were like there's one it's there's one
more game left so be ready in 10 minutes so they didn't they
thought they thought flats was gonna 3 oh damn
they really thought flats was gonna 3 oh but but man no
faith no because they're like get ready in 10 minutes the
last the game is about to end no no confidence at all always
i was a believer i was a fucking believer um oh no no that
means i have to wait a lot wait no wait i have to wait
longer than oh my god not the way even longer no okay let's
gotta take the next point so then we can get the show match
going on it's like I was like, oh no.
Sia, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, he has to do the show match.
I mean, into the tournament and into the show match.
I mean, his team is fucking stacked as hell.
His team is already pretty fucking stacked.
um um he has literally has siphate ttk moxie wada and prism
that team is like pretty damn good i don't think i guess
like who are the pros on the other team vision and is a
forky dog no it can't be a forky dog because or is it tyke
who's team flat flight against pizza vision Eric Cartman
isn't Eric Cartman the not not the South Park Eric Cartman
Eric Cartman from South Park no there's a guy named Eric
Cartman and rivals and he's like a penny one trick so I'm
like isn't that the guy who only plays penny like from South
Park is it forky oh it's forky okay it's forky and vision is
their pros um that that's pretty impressive because like um
I would assume that like um that's pretty impressive uh that
uh uh because there's like eric carmen the penny one not
apparently not a one trick the penny player pizza the melee
specialist uh forky and vision as their uh pro players i
don't know who tyke is i don't know who manda is but like
it's pretty impressive they got the semi-finals because a
lot of the like more well known teams got knocked out so
early on and i think this team yeah the manda panda's team
knocked out uh no not mandy manda the manda's panda's team
knocked out tara's team and tara's team was like the fucking
favorite to win the entire championship because like their
team was so fucking good but i guess they just don't know
how to deal with mr fantastic
knocked out Terra's team during like um the the top eight
bracket but like to be fair when pro players fight against
like the same meta over and over again and then there's some
random mr fantastic like yeah like mr fantastic and and it's
working you're like what the fuck do I do I've never fucking
prepped for this I'm never fucking prepped for mr fantastic
like yeah nobody like one of the games they they literally
won one of the maps they won one of the maps because pizza
was on mr.
fantastic and they're like i can't believe we can't deal
with one mr.
fantastic like i remember i was watching the the i just
pulled up the stream because like someone um my team was
like when uh someone i don't remember like i think like
someone someone was messaging me being like Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Pizza's team is winning.
And then I pulled up one.
Like Tara.
I think it was.
I pulled up Tara's stream.
And then.
I don't remember which teammate.
But one of them was like.
How.
Why can't we kill one fantastic?
Like how are we losing to this fantastic?
Like.
It's.
It's just, it's just the fact that they did, I feel like
they just, they just didn't train for it, because they're
not used to playing against, against, like, weird-ass cops.
I mean, he is pretty fantastic.
He sure is.
Oh, my God.
All right, what do we do then?
I, I guess we queue up.
Oh, man, but I don't want to.
lose i don't want to be c1 and i don't want to be c3 in the
show match i can't even play a game i'm too much of a coward
to lose celestio too right now right before the show match
i'm i'm too much of a coward also everybody or are you
secure it's quick plays i will do one quick play i'm like
what the do i do now
all right we'll do a quick there i should i don't really
feel like playing i was like i really feel like who
acquitted too late what the do i do while we wait there was
a game that wanted to try out oh my god we could do call of
the lamb actually and do uh i haven't played call of lamb in
so long but i heard they like updated it with a lot of new
shit and i have sort of one i love the twitch i love the
twitch feature that they add to it who's on my team it's
flats me lulu uh i already forgot give me a say i said it
like 200 times i already forgot malaya day craiggy sad six i
think that's six i suppose you could Oh my god, I should sit
up.
UGH!
Quarantine zone?
That's too much thinking right now.
I just want to react.
My brain is not awake right now.
My eyes are so fucking heavy.
You know what?
To fit how I feel right.
This is how I actually feel right now.
Oh my god, I haven't seen this map in 80 years.
React?
The thing is, I didn't prep my stream to pull up my Chrome.
So I'll pull out my browser and I always never trust myself
if I don't prep beforehand.
Like, I'm just scared of accidentally doxing myself.
Or, like, leaking anything.
Because I don't trust myself.
I'm incompetent.
And I know it.
Bro, how long has this guy been beating me up?
Oh, goodbye.
Where's my support?
I am not aiming right now.
I should really start aiming.
Whoa!
I did not expect him to show up.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
Let's play again.
I need, I should do full speed.
screen mode i should never doesn't mean i will i think we're
losing so much what the how is he allowed to just shoot me
from behind
i don't like that i don't like that he's just allowed to do
that
where is my oh my god please please why would you fucking on
backwards oh my god why would you all into him too i have so
many questions like there is actually nowhere to uh i missed
the one shot oh my god thank god i'm warming up
oh my god i am most deaf no the thing body blocked me
They're coming with me!
No matter what!
That's why you're not hiding from me too!
I see you!
I'm dead.
There you go.
I see you.
Alright, I got three guys.
In one all I became the ace.
I got mine.
All it took was one and I became the best player in the
world.
Or in this lobby.
Look at that.
That's all it took.
I assumed that...
There we go.
It's fine.
I got him out of Hulk form.
That's not fair!
Amma ulted and got ace now!
It's alright.
Second best.
SVP.
Doesn't hurt to be SVP.
There we go.
Let's go.
my eyes my eyes are so tired thank god i'm on support the
easiest role in game
until i get dope until until in a in a supports not the
easiest role in in an eu apparently apparently only in an a
is it's the easiest role i will say that like
The moment I get dope, it's over.
It's over.
Yeah.
No, no, trust me.
I'm not aiming right now.
I'm actually so tired.
My aim is actually a lot better.
A lot better when I'm actually awake.
When I'm actually awake.
It's, I see you.
This must be all how the hell it feels whenever I fucking...
Okay, apparently I don't see him.
This is my lazy...
Like, I would have killed... I would have hit that.
Literally my first game of the day.
No warm-up.
Please don't kill me.
Oh...
it's okay we chill I think I believe in my team all right
three people died all right let me it's time to you even
said please I think it was up come on there we go I feel
like I should help her no oh shit get my cloak Don't get me!
Please, aim for the club, not me!
Alright, there we go.
Alright, I think I might need coffee.
Alright.
We got this.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go.
Also realize I'm not on full screen right now.
If I was on full screen, maybe it'll be better.
I'm no, I say as I cope.
Maybe if I was on full screen.
Let's do it.
Warm up, warm up.
First game of the day.
But I feel like...
Alright, that's good.
I was a little worried.
Wait.
Is it raw input?
No, okay.
I cannot do raw input.
I know everybody uses raw input, but my muscle memory is so
trained without using raw input that, like, I just...
I'm too lazy to go...
To retrain it.
I'm too lazy.
I know I shouldn't, but...
There's no way they know, right?
Like, get me out of here.
Alright.
I was like, there's no way they see me, right?
Stop healing!
I'm leaving this.
I assume that maybe if I shoot in this general direction,
that somebody will be in there.
How did he die?
Oh, I got you, Ultron!
Remember what I'm doing for you!
You're welcome, I'm a hero.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
Really?
He lives?
I wish I had healers like that.
Oh!
I might like get knocked out soon.
That's right!
That was like the most... I forgot about this thing.
I...
It's okay.
I got my one.
I forgot that that exists.
Oh, double stun.
That's awkward.
Alright.
Look, I did my job.
I got one guy.
Like, that should be, like, enough.
Oh, goodbye.
It's quick play.
I needed to warm up.
I'm so tired right now.
My aim is, like, super lazy.
I shall claim my victory.
Yeah, apparently, okay, J3 was like, there's only 10 minutes
left of this game.
Remember to get there in time because he didn't sink.
He thought Flats was going to 3-0.
And then the other team got a point in the last game.
So now, so we're, we got wait.
They might actually reverse, they could reverse sweep it.
Hey, missed though.
God, that fucking strafe is pretty neat.
This strafe is pretty good, I will admit.
Oh, whatever.
I'll stand here.
Yeah, I almost got her.
That was a pretty neat strafe that she had.
I know.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
That's it.
It's time.
It's Call of Duty time.
Oh, wait.
That's not Sorry, I, like, whatever.
SILOC chat.
Wait, were they?
Yeah, it's fine.
There's no way I'll get fucked up, right?
It's alright.
I'm thinking about Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, they won?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That was fast.
I thought we were going to have another 30-minute game.
Alright.
Don't worry, I'm almost done.
I mean, should I just leave?
Do I just leave?
Like, I'm not going to start right away, right?
Oh, they're on domination.
Yep, and Moxie might win his first tournament.
His first Rival's tournament.
I believe.
I honestly don't know that...
I'm going to peel.
Never mind.
I leave.
I no longer want to peel.
I no longer want to help my team.
Boy, I actually forgot where the door is.
Wait, I could still help him.
Alright, it's fine.
We're fine.
I'm gonna go this way.
Oh, really?
That's fine.
I'll try and think.
Maybe they're here.
I will attempt to predict where they are.
Oh my god, this is so illegal.
It's like they're pocketing each other or something.
I know their game just finished up.
I'm just... I'm on domination too, so it'll be fast.
No, I haven't seen this map in 80 years.
So I'm like, where is everything?
That's it!
That's right!
Fuck that hook!
Oh, never mind.
I didn't realize the hawk can jump away.
That's crazy.
What the fuck?
Their support's got like the pocket of their lifetime.
At least I'm so tired.
Don't think that's it!
I'm going Punisher.
That's fucking... Oh fuck.
Okay, we're gonna fight this.
Never mind.
I was like, that's it.
I really want a shotgun to these guys.
Oh my god.
It must be nice to get pocketed.
Oh, hey, I got a pocket.
He has a lot.
I'm just going to damage for him real quick.
As long as none of us cap the point, we're on our pathway to
finishing this game.
There we go.
We're not going to win, but let it...
Oh my god, they're actually patty-kicking each other!
What am I looking at?
I thought it was a quick game!
They're actually patty-kicking in quick play!
Oh my god, that's crazy!
They did a patty-kicking quick play!
They need this win.
I was not expecting what?
Alright, that's unfortunate.
It's fine.
That makes the game quick.
I legitimately was not expecting patty-kaking quickly.
Bucky, please!
I needed your help because they're patty-kaking!
I need one more DPS to shoot her!
I can't deal!
I can't kill them!
Thanks!
Punch you!
They're patty kicking.
I need one more DPS to shoot him.
He's learning.
At least it's over.
I can go to my game.
Oh, good.
But yeah, I didn't want to win anyway.
Bro, how the fuck?
I was not expecting Ace with that gameplay.
I was not expecting Ace.
I really...
It means they're like fucking covering each other like two
supports are just pocketing